[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong it's your girl
Jacqueline and we're here with another
episode to kick off the Christmas season
Mariah Carey is in her full bag ladies
and gentlemen and we are here with a
familyfriendly film that we feel the
critics were a little bit unfair to I'm
so excited to have my co-host along with
me again today Mr Mark Ellis I know this
is right around the time where your
Amazon Wish lists start coming over yeah
this is I'm so bad at putting together
my mom will text me without fail like
December 1st and she's like okay Santa's
on the line what do you like and I'm
like I I like socks now like I'm at that
age where the stuff that I hated getting
as a kid is the stuff I need now so my
mom hooks me up with socks she hooks me
up with uh she need to get you some
shirts this year then tell her the
t-shirts yeah I just I'm not big on
t-shirts I'm just you have to wear
sleeves sorry she's going to give me one
big wake farest sweatshirt and that's
going to carry me through to next year
you have to to wear sleeves that are not
part of a hoodie I think our guest who
is looking very Dapper next to him will
agree of course this is our man Tony
Baker joining us today to talk about
family man with Nicholas Cage Tony sir
welcome to Rotten Tomatoes is wrong glad
to have you here to talk about it as a
family man yourself thanks for having me
it's good to be here it's good to be
back in the Rotten Tomatoes mix good to
see you in person as to post onto my TV
CU Anytime I'm watching the games like
Tony's on every other commercial he's
popping up yeah he's just he's a he's an
omnipresent for my life even when we
haven't seen each other the man is
working which we're going to talk about
another man working in this one that of
course is the 2000 I would say dramedy
cult classic a little bit there's a lot
of folks that are fan of this one it's
53% rotten on the Tomato Meter but it
has a 65 67% audience score it's a Nick
Cage movie so of course it's going to be
on our editorial feature Nick Cage
movies ranked it is on the Lower Side uh
at the 53% ranked at number 47 the very
bottom one is Left Behind at 93 three
that was part of likely the Nicholas
Cage trying to pay off the tax man phase
but number one in 97% is a movie that I
love but the person who lives in my
house is not a fan of and that's Pig uh
from 2021 it's also on the 150 best
Christmas movies of all time number one
on that one is cang cang clang with the
try and meet me in St Louis family man
is ranked at number 107 oh it couldn't
break the top hundred I mean Christmas
movies at least it's on the list like
let's be real Christmas movies Run Deep
we could name at least 20 Banger ones
and we are a firm believer that die hard
is on the list and I know for a fact Die
Hard ranks higher than this and die hard
and die hard too I want to see this
little Meet Me In St Louis from 1944 how
is it better than Die Hard you do not
come for Judy Garland like I'm glad
you're here but you are a guest in this
house there 44 man they probably didn't
even talk nor the gays are going to come
for you sir you need to leave that one
alone say she's ay I what she's doing
this holiday season she Willers hey
what's going on here Santa what's the
big idea oh my God oh my God probably
like 10 critics they reviewed that no
they oh my God the the TCM crowd is
going to come through this microphone
and stab you both but before we have
them do that I will go ahead and just at
least start off with a place where I
think we should which is Mark can you at
least tell us a little bit about family
man cuz this is this is a movie that
involves I I don't even know what I'm
going to call it time travel I've been
waiting for this this is almost like
alternate universe kind of stuff because
Nicholas Cage plays a man who is very
successful in bu without a family at the
outset of this movie so you can kind of
look at this as Christmas Carol with a
little bit of through the looking glass
with it because it's a wonderful life
Wonder life It's a Wonderful Life as
well because it's about the choices that
you didn't make it's about the the
alternative steps you could have taken
in your life and where that would have
landed you where you get a glimpse as
our character who sort of the Clarence
the angel of this story Don played by
Don cheel introduces Nick Cage by a
weird incident at a convenience store on
Christmas Eve that you know what I'm
going to show you what your life could
have been like so Nicholas Cage goes to
bed in his nice New York City highrise
by himself the way he likes it and he
wakes up and who is he in bed with taone
and who comes in the room two kids and a
huge dog oh my God he's been married to
his sweetheart for 15 years as opposed
to the decision he actually made where
he got on the plane and he didn't come
back for her so now he has to live this
life knowing what he knows about his
other life and he's like I don't belong
here I want to go back to my nice little
oh but wait now this family is starting
to grow me a little bit and I meet the
neighbor oh this is a community and it's
very different life than I thought I'd
have I work at a tire store and I'm just
selling tires at retail but I kind of
feel a connection to this family and
this woman that I've loved my whole life
never stopped loving her what's going to
happen is she going to feel the same way
about him back in this other world it's
a it's a collision of universes and
feelings and emotion and the perfect
time to do all that is the season of
giving yeah for sure I mean this one
definitely puts you in the fields if you
have a family that you like this will be
the movie that makes you like not take
them for granted which is amazing Tony
uh I'm going to start with you just real
quick because we're going to dive deep
in movie talk but before we get there if
you can just tell me is Rotten Tomatoes
wrong like are you how do you feel about
this having just watched it um I'm not
surprised that they didn't like it just
because critics can be harsh on good
stuff like if it's too you know on the
nose with the you know the message like
I don't like it you know critical snobs
cuz you know It's a Wonderful Life
bombed when he came out that is true so
it's like they don't appreciate what's
good but but when family man came out I
remember it doing well at the box office
it had good legs it made like 70
something million uh the budget was high
but it still did better than anticipated
yeah no and so made back that proved
that you know audience is like I like
this and so I feel like so I'm not
surprised and they're tough on Nicholas
Cage yeah this was also in the $ 20
million Nicholas Cage realm too I should
be very clear this is when he started
making his uh bigger bigger paychecks he
had become an action star off of The
Rock in the mid 90s and Conair and and
Gone in 60 Seconds and stuff like that
and something that I noticed because I
haven't seen this movie uh in a minute I
came to this movie late I hadn't seen it
in a minute the first scene of him was
just walking around in his skibbies and
he's got like a he's like he's pretty
built and I'm like this dude's
definitely been working out then it hit
me and I was like oh my God he's in
Superman shape right now he was about to
play Superman and Tim Burton Superman
lives and then my our late great buddy
John schneep made the documentary the
death of super Liv what happened about
how the fall out of that but it's like
you're watching it and oh my God this
guy's about to play K Ken no what and
he's also like a a rich single dude who
basically he works hard and then he
works out hard and then he hooks up hard
Yeahs up hard and it fits in at the time
I think he had just maybe worked with
Scorsese at this time too cuz he had
just recently maybe done bring out the
dead or he's about to do bring out the
dead it's somewhere around this time he
loved it he he counts that as one of his
top five Mar does uh no uh Nichols cage
Nichols cage does um let's go ahead and
find out what the critics were saying at
the time I hope that Tim is not as maybe
as forceful as Tony um let's let's hope
we got Good Vibes for this one and see
what the critics were saying in our
segment we like to call 2 minutes with
Tim two minutes with Tim Frank capras
It's a Wonderful Life is the rarely
disputed choice for the greatest
Christmas movie of all time and when
people say a movie is capra-esque what
they're describing as a kind of
old-fashioned feel-good tale of the
little guy sticking up for good old
American values in other words It's a
Wonderful Life and its broad outline but
if you're watching it for the first time
you're likely to be taken back by how
dark much of it is there are moments in
It's a Wonderful Life that are as tough
and despairing as any film Noir of its
ERA this is a movie that earns its happy
ending it was inevitable that the family
man would draw comparisons to its a
wonderful life it's another holiday tale
about a man who through traumatic
Supernatural means gets to see an
alternate version of his world but
critics were largely mixed with many
finding it more schaly and calculated
than heartfelt and others enjoying the
strong Chemistry Between Nicholas Cage
and TI Leone the family man is rotten at
53% on the Tomato me with 130 reviews
and it has a 67% audience score so what
did the critics have to say in a rotten
review Joe Laden a variety called The
Family Man a slickly produced slice of
sentimental Hokum that borrows freely
from a half dozen or so other better
feel-good fantasies however in a fresh
review Paul Clinton of CNN.com wrote yes
this movie is schaly but so what it's
also heartfelt a great date movie and
perfect for the holidays the Rotten
Tomato critics consensus reads the
family man's Earnest attempt to remind
audiences that it's a wonderful life too
often steers into schals although
Nicholas Cage and ta Leone's romantic
Rapport adds a dash of sincere sweetness
so that's the family man Merry Christmas
to all and to all a good night back to
you folks just like our little tiny Tim
I love it so great I kind of like
Schmaltz I'm with I'm I I I take this
even a step further than Tony I I think
this definitely is a fresh movie I think
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong and I feel like
you have the same inkling as I do yes I
was going to say I completely forgot to
ask both me and Mark on what we wanted
to do I wanted to hear what Tim said
before I went I did I really did I
wanted to get there uh I think for me
it's about right like it's about right
f53 f53 like I'm not like warming up out
of bed with this I had a really great
time with it this is a joke that has
one one bit and they ring that bit until
the end and it's cute but it's not like
it goes any place it's you know what I
mean like the what you want is what you
get the guy doesn't take his life for
granted there's a little bit of a Twist
at the end that keeps you kind of
interested yeah I like a movie like this
because it keeps us talking about what
what does happen like like I I I kind of
like want to fanfiction where they go
from here a little bit where the movie
leaves off you know and I like when
something does that like you see a movie
in the theater like if three of us go to
see family man and then we go get
something to eat or have a drink
afterwards and we're all talking about
like what else could have happened yeah
you know so that that that's kind of The
Vibes that I like with this movie I
again it's not that it's badge SMS it's
just not SM I I particularly think is
that great there's better SMY stuff like
What's Eating Gilbert Grape is smalts to
a certain extent and it's better than
this like because he takes his family
for granted and then eventually he loves
it very different but I see what you're
saying different way different movie but
I I get it any for me it's like you know
53% it could go up to 60 know fresh 3 60
get it to Fresh I think it could be a
low fresh but but it's not like you know
it wasn't amazing it wasn't like I left
the theater like oh okay that was cute
do you like this better than son-in-law
which was our last like sort of holiday
movie that's what I'm like you got to
like have this is me being like
Christian towards you again where I'm
like getting you to compare your things
so I apologize for being this toxic but
I'm like come on this is kind ofy I'm a
sucker for any sort of Christmas Carol
esque
story I feel like this has a little bit
more of that and this opens a gateway to
introduce new generations to the Frank
kapper stuff and like it's a wonderful
life things like that so I feel like
nichas cage is a nice gateway to get to
Jimmy Stewart so I think I kind of like
this a little more than sonin sorry
paully I love you we'll get into this in
movie talk but I I just think I'm I'm at
a on a different point in my journey I
can't I I look at families as dangerous
entities that it's almost like an mln
that they're trying to like draft other
people into the the oldest MLM is
motherhood and fames I'm not going to
let you come at me like this is
Beachbody or Monette like I don't care I
don't want to subscribe and movies like
this are the gateway drug so I look at
them like I have a I have a retort that
I will issue on the other side of yes
let's talk about it when we get into
movie talk Brian cu the
[Music]
music we're going to need Tony the
family man to break us up here jacine I
don't want to look let's start with
let's let's actually have a pallet
cleanser first because before we get
into to the to the Deep of it cuz I know
this is going to like cause issues
because again Mark is a man who
literally travels around the country to
see his family at Christmas and I
pretend like you need to put out a
wanted poster so we are definitely on
opposite sides of the spectrum when it
comes to this but let's start with
coming on for Christmas put her on the
Milk Carton now it's July put her on the
Milk Carton now we'll see if we can get
her home she not pulling up on the
family this holiday season that's you uh
let's move
on to whether or not you're a fan of CH
I am a fan of Christmas movies but as I
will state in this I like the
dysfunctional ones I like the ones that
it's like let's like you know I give me
some mix nuts give me some home for the
holidays give me the type of family
where you got to like bite your tongue
in between you know what I mean the
family St going to say Family Stone give
me that give me a meshman give me John
mlan can't talk to his wife but he's
going to pick up a gun I am
there movie right there you know what I
me die hard really is the best or the
Goblet of fire where they leave the poor
boy abandoned at hwart I think that
one's done at like Christmas Eve like
people feel like Goblet of Fire is like
a low-key Christmas movie cuz that was
the year that he that he stayed and like
they had Christmas there was that or was
that Chamber of Secrets where they were
in trouble I feel like all of them were
Christmas all of them are like that they
felt like Christmas Hogwarts has a
christmy Vibe you get a frozen
butterbeer and you get you kind of walk
around but on that Frozen even Frozen
that family is more realistic than the
crap they're pulling in this this movie
it's kind of like the Harry Potter where
like you're saying over at school that
movie with Paul Gatti I haven't seen yet
the hold over amazing rave reviews and
and I kind of like those dysfunctional
Christmas movies too there's also a soft
SP in my in my heart for like for the
elf you know kind of that Stu the world
Garfield's Christmas is one of the best
Christmas Tales I've ever seen and but
it all again goes back to me either uh A
Christmas Carol with like George C Scott
or Patrick Stewart or uh Scrooge with
Bill Murray scro love functional
though dysfunction Christmas vacation is
probably one of my favorite and it was
just disastrous there you go you know
what I mean I love it but see it's it's
funny to think about those two movies
right because you're looking at at
ebener Scrooge and a more modern Scrooge
like Frank cross's played by Bill Murray
and Scrooge where he's looking at this
alternate version of his life that would
have been like The Griswalds where like
you're sacrificing a lot of income and a
lot of work and like a lot of material
possessions for this nice middle class
family situation that you know Park's
just hoping on his Christmas bonus the
same way that anybody who lives in the
neighborhood of Nick Gage and tone once
they get into that situation they're
kind of the same way so it's like it's
fun watching them just get by just
struggle to make it but they do it with
a smile on their face and With a Song in
their heart and I think that's where a
lot of the critics go yeah the schz you
do need to see the holdovers it again is
more my brand of dysfunction rather than
the SMY side of it but I will also say
to The Descendants which is Hawaii
Christmas
yeah where Mom gets found out to be
that's a Christmas movie cuz she's
coming home for Christmas
remember anyway so uh that I I will say
those are the type of Christmas movies I
like the other ones it's I can't my the
cynic in me is like this is a SC I got
beef with one element in this movie man
what is it like when he wanted when he
tried to to go back to New York and and
and do something that he loved to do she
kind of shot it down I didn't like that
she you don't want to sell tires in this
movie there's a couple times when when
wife is a little I mean look I give
taone a lot of credit for multiple
reasons because again I am like Nick
Cage when he wakes up at the beginning
of this movie like that's my Nick Cage
that's kind of me that's I like being by
myself you know you might have romantic
diance and goes nowhere every so often
I'm kind of Nick Cage in this movie
right a few a few zeros in the bank
account less but I'm Nick Cage in this
movie then he wakes up and it's like
nothing about this situation I want I
don't want these kids this who's this
dog I have to walk every morning who are
these friends but I'm married to taonei
and who plays Kate in this movie and
that is a that's what a selling point
that is so whatever that woman told me
to do as much as I love to be
independent just sit and like get high
with my dog after the end of the night
if taone comes into life and she's like
hey you need to do this and this and
this and stop doing this and this and
this like man I want to do what I love
to do for a Liv but wait a minute though
Tony like again I'm not trying to say
that you're wrong on the reaction or the
defensiveness of it but like let's be
real the reality of her being supportive
of that what reality does that leave for
her that means that everything that
she's doing which is already tough I
mean the first moment of the movie she's
like busting in on him like oh my God I
got a pee I need to get away from the
kids for two seconds here take this you
know what I mean this is clearly a
frazzled overworked mom who although she
is not the businesswoman that we meet at
the beginning of the thing that chick is
still in there and so you don't think
she wakes up some morning wanting to be
in Midtown Manhattan taking martinis at
lunch and so like him asking that like
yeah wouldn't you be like be for real
but now it's like at least let him
attempt let him attempting what is her
world G to be like this I'm also saying
this to a man who leaves four days out
of the week so I don't feel like I'm
talking to the Right
audience cuz I'm a firm believer you got
to do what you love to do in life fair
and you know and you know some people
can balance family and that at the same
time and I know it's a struggle but you
know I know she got blindsided by this
decision right decision because
basically this is the point of the movie
where he started to embrace who he is
and that he is this family man and that
this is sort of something that he did
want for a long time he's married to the
person he's he's never not been in love
with and then you know you come with the
kids and the kids are okay and I kind of
like walking the dog after a while and
whatever uh so he's accepted that but
then he gets this out ofth blue
opportunity to prove how talented he is
in this other world and to take his
family with him I mean again I'm all for
Kate saying like what the hell are you
doing moving our family to New York this
is crazy no we're not doing it then he
drops the bomb uh it's going to be
double the paycheck and I get a big
Christmas bonus it's guaranteed unlike
cart Griswalds and it's like we got to
at least think about there's a
conversation you have familyes in New
York City not going to pretend that it
was not something to be contemplated but
let's not keep it real what life the
life changes the life changes for her at
the end of that and I'm not saying
that's Nanny money we're not saying
that's Nanny money cuz I would be like
is that Nanny money in which case let's
pack up the kids and let's go defin
Nanny money but just this is this is
2000 it was before the first economic
downturns you're probably right it is
Nanny they can buy a condo for 100 grand
this movie does such a great job though
and something we were talking about
right before we we hit play on this
stuff is uh is like it it does such a
great job of painting the picture of how
a single Bachelor dude lives in the city
and how non-conducive that is to raising
a family just the environment that he
wakes up in where it's just cold static
you know set up exactly the way he likes
but you take a kid in there and they're
bored out of their mind there's like
nothing to do there's hazards everywhere
there's sharp corners and it's like this
is this is the antithesis of the family
home where we can move in and grow old
together and oh this is leaking and
that's broken but it's ours Tony I'm
going to talk to you this is why I think
the movie is fine where it is and I'm
going to ask
just name some of the movies that you
notice this movie rips off in it because
as you were talking about that I thought
of like three more so what so we know
it's like you know it's wonderful life
very similar but there's more like I got
one 17 Again there you go oh wow didn't
rip it off cuz it's after but like very
similar like that Vibe of like big like
you know going back in time sure vice
versa vice versa per perfect example
what else what else we got that it robs
from there's like a ton there's been
movies that have come out since then no
there's one before uh American Psycho
because his opening office tell me
that's not Patrick bait's layer wow tell
me that's not Patrick Ba's layer PA's
card a very American Psy he this guy
listens to huie Lewis I'll say that
thank you so like again like look at and
then um we said a wonderful life we said
that also A Christmas Story Ebenezer
Scrooge and like going to see his
different versions of his life oh it's
definitely a Christmas carol Christmas
Carol I said
yeah yeah how many other movies does
this thing rip off that's why I can't
like give it it's it's kind of a Franken
Christmas I think the thing that that
separates it is and and even the critics
who lamb based this movie who gave it a
rotten review even they had to admit
that the chemistry between yes cage and
Leone is what sells this movie and I
think that that's the attraction for
somebody coming out like me who
historically is not a relationship guy
like my record is 2 years okay I
achieved that in college I achieved that
with Molly's mom and since
2017 it's been pretty much on my own now
there's been instances and there's been
like datings and stuff like that that
since I actually had a girlfriend yeah
and and I don't feel sad about it at all
I actually kind of love it but but there
is this there's this Allure to having
somebody to having like a teammate in
life and that's who these folks are like
you can tell obviously you can tell that
they're in love and and I love any movie
which again this does borrow from a few
any of those those romcoms where at the
end it's like she's at the airport I got
to catch her can I get there Tony plays
a cab I'll get you there in 20 minutes
Jack you know it's like you hope that
you can make that work because you love
this person so much um I don't know that
person's out there for me but the the
just the alternate universe aspect of it
I think it's appealing I think it's fun
sometimes and it's usually around the
holidays you just sit and you're like
where else could my life have gone if I
had taken that internship if I didn't
decide to pick up a microphone in front
of people where could my life have gone
and that generally leads me down the
road of I probably would have been
settled with a family yeah yeah is that
I mean do you this is I hate to say it
this is the midlife crisis movie though
and I really feel that I am in the wrong
audience for this like like me not like
this movie is not made for me this movie
is made for yall and this is like I feel
like I'm like a guy talking about Barbie
right now and I should be out of this
because in really truth like this movie
was made for y'all written by David and
David David Diamond and David Weissman I
have a feeling they were working some
stuff out oh my God I just
saw rner baby Rush Hour this is
definitely the midlife crisis movie that
dude rner rner I I get it now I know now
I by the way I want everyone to please
like hit us up if you think I'm right
about this because I really think I just
cracked the case this is like a sub dude
Brett rner this being a middle-aged like
dude's kind of you know not not Revenge
movie but just like where else could my
life have gone should should I buy that
sports car kind of thing Brian put a
great nugget in here is that in in our
notes is that Nick Cage agreed to do
this movie because he saw rush hour he
was a huge fan of Rush Hour okay and so
that movie continues to have connective
DNA with us here at Rotten Tomatoes and
especially the show Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong so that's that's a really funny
thing and like when this movie came out
in December of of 2000 and like how much
when you see the shots in New York City
this movie how much our world was about
to change and you this I think even more
so in retrospect knowing all that yeah
it makes it feel like we're going back
to a simpler time but you brought up
Barbie and you brought up how you know
like because I loved Barbie I thought it
was maybe the best movie I've seen this
year oh this feels like Barbie too yeah
because you're taking somebody out of
their comfort zone where margar Robbie
wakes up and she's in the Barbie
Dreamhouse and she has his Barbie life
and she knows Barbie things and that's
her entire world and she loves it and
you put her a different universe and
she's like I don't know how to feel but
I but maybe I do belong in this world
yeah no one it else it Robs a little bit
from Labyrinth going to rescue the life
that you abandoned I'm telling you man
this movie is just a Frankenstein movie
of schaly lot of movies lot movies it's
so BL whole catalog I don't disagree
with you on that but he puts some
eloquence to it you know what I'm saying
like there's no eloquence to this one it
is it's not there's a different between
a light touch on your booty at a party
and grabbing and this movie is grabbing
for it you know what I'm saying there
has to be a scene you like in this movie
though I do like I do like I do like
watching him as a fish out of water as
the you know whatever it is as the the
guy that's waking up in the life like
basically um remember in the change up
with Ryan Reynolds and Jason Jason
bitman like all those moments where he
is just out of his depth with a woman
that is like why don't you know how to
do this you've been doing this for 20
years those are all really funny what
about you Tony do you have a favorite
scene from this one I did like the
chocolate cake scene cuz that that was
the moment where they really connected
you know what I'm saying they were
chasing each other for the cake and then
there food involved and then you know
that that was the moment CU you know he
was out he was one foot out he was like
he was thinking about hooking up with
that girl in the red dress and and
Jeremy was like what are you talking
about man and so I feel like that was
the moment of real connection with them
on that you know aspect of it and it was
like and just seeing that that personal
it right there I was like I like this
couple right here and we see them run
the entire gamut of his character in
that one scene which is why it's so
perfect is because he comes home and all
he's thinking about is that chocolate
cake because as a single dude nobody's
stealing my chocolate cake opening my
fridge and whatever I ordered yeah right
it's like whatever we grubbed up the
night before is still going to be in
there it's guaranteed and now this
stranger is eating my chocolate cake but
you realize through in in the span of
watching her eat it and take it and and
ban I love even more I love this
chocolate C and then we get a tease of
and half weeks and then he says the
wrong thing and realizes he's still out
of his depth and so we still have some
work to do that's a great great scene I
love the uh the the Christmas Eve party
scene oh yeah because that is every
Christmas Eve party that I went to
growing up as a kid my grandma threw
like the big in town in roing New Jersey
New Year's Eve party where like all the
neighbors would come in and it was not a
big house so it's like everybody's just
kind of packed but you're seeing
relatives and you only see them that
time of year and you find these little
Corners where it's like oh I'm safe with
with you three I can now now now I'm in
a safe space it's like you know and and
the guy who's eating chicken wings cuz
he's got his bypass in two days like
it's so it just it feels so like that
small town like this should be Green Bay
Wisconsin you know that's why are you
doing that to my Green Bay it it just
that's what this feels like it does feel
more like that are they in Upstate New
York when we when we Jersey Jersey
they're in Jersey Jersey cuz they're
hoping the Nets can turn it around
withth
Jesus definitely da right there the one
thing I will say about this and you
mentioned it too is Jeremy being has
there's some great supporting casts in
this which also really sort of make this
movie also the kids the kids are
adorable the kids were like really cute
but the Jeremy pivot of it all and we
were talking about this the other day
you think this is his best like Apex
Jeremy Piven because he had such a great
run of being the best friend in romantic
comedies whereas usually next to John
Cusack like Gross Point Blank or
Serendipity but he's also just great
hero when he shows up and it's just like
he's just that perfect sort of second
bananatic guy you can lean on in certain
scenes like the bowling alley scene
where he has to do what he thinks is a
solid for his friend because his friend
who he's known the Nick Cage that he's
known this whole time talked him out of
a similar thing the year before of of
not cheating and like again it goes back
to that this is probably written by
dudes going through their own midlife
crisis for sure again I I know that like
it's like oh I get this like it's so not
for me and let me tell you I was very
entitled to this movie I was like I
don't get this why this works I I even
remember that it was directed by Brett
Ratner I would I would have been harsher
on it I would have probably been harsher
on it if I would have known that I'm
sorry whatever he started it he started
it and everyone knows what he did you
did not start it Jack he started it um
luckily he's canceled so I don't have to
worry about it um the thing I will say
about it is uh the whole premise of this
movie not being for me is because if I
woke up with a whole family although I
would be upset about it it wouldn't be
like something where I was like I don't
know who this person is I would be like
we made some poor choices but I wouldn't
like you know I could I take care of
people now you know what I mean like it
would suck but I wouldn't like die about
it what would you do if you another fun
question to ask is like how would I
handle that
think know how I would that situ and I
would do my J and I would suck it up and
I would be the best godamn small town
dad and I would love the kids and I
would cherish my dog walks at night by
myself and I would love worship my wife
for the Goddess that she is and I'd be
like okay this is it this is it but but
much in the same way that he had his
attitude towards work where he's like
this you know he's he's working on this
Mega billion dollar deal in his other
life and now he's working as the the
assistant at Big Ed's Tires I'm like I'm
getting a management baby I'm taking
over this this location we're opening
three new locations by this time next
year because you just you have to
understand what your loud in life is and
the fact that there's such a lack of the
angel of Don cheo's Angel in the be in
the meat of this movie where like he
wants him to show up and give him some
sort of hey maybe you should walk over
here maybe you should check out what's
going on here he's pretty much figuring
this thing out on
and but that's why Don such a great book
into this movie too how would you handle
waking up and being in that situation if
you just came from like just comic on
the road no then you wake up and boom Oh
my God I have a a full-blown as gen C
calls it a full-blown family full-blown
family um I would probably get used to
it really quickly like you know what I'm
saying cuz I've already had experience
with with the wife from the past
relationship like oh we we doing this we
did this and and the kids you know I'm
great with kids so it's like but for me
the whole thing is the job what am I
doing for what you doing to make cuz my
my dream in life personally I've always
I always knew I was GNA find love or
good mate like I've never worried about
that not to be cocky or anything like
that but it's just like don't it's not
always knew I would have a
companion if you're listening to the
show you might want to fire up YouTube
because this is a catch right next to me
cuz it's like you know I know I can find
somebody cuz I Vibe well so so for me
the scarier part of life for me is will
I do something for a living that I enjoy
that was always like the dream for me
and so once I pull up the big Big Al
Tires I'm just
like bro but like you said if if I could
if I can turn that business around and
make it my own and put my stamp on it
and then we we going global now then I
can then then I can live with big girl
boss you both girl boss
the job is crucial we know the highest
of highs we we know the high of of of of
having a great set and you walk off
stage and it's just like it all came
together I feel like I could we could
simulate that if you make a big snow
tire sale and then you just go back in
in my tiny little office we open that
bottle of Glenn Liv's hiding in his
thing he's just like you know let's
celebrate this way you can never accuse
comedians of not being ambitious now
they may be not ambitious about that
other people care about but they're all
ambitious because to just do that is
such a grind like all of you have been
like meat ground on it like I think the
thing about comics and how they relate
to this and being in that situation
waking up in this weird world where now
all of a sudden you have all these
responsibilities is that when you're a
comic and you go somewhere on the road
you don't necessarily have say over how
the crowd's going to be that night over
over if the mic's even going to work is
this plugged in is this going to work is
somebody going to drop it spill a drink
somebody going to Heckle you have to
suck it whatever situation you're in you
have to suck it up and deliver for an
hour and so with this it's the rest of
your life but you're like I'm I have to
make the best of this so I just hope
that occasionally I get to go home at
the end of the night and the chocolate
cake isn't eaten the chocolate um also
you're good improviser so you're going
to amuse yourself for sure within the
absurdity of it I will say on the other
side of it I would do it differently in
the sense that I would look at this as a
chance to just make this my game I would
Captain Fantastic like I would take the
kids out to the country and we would be
homeschooled like I everybody already
knows I am just like one Global event
away from like being the unibomber
basically without the propensity for
violence like it is there my desire to
leave the world and grow in the dirt has
been within me since I was a child like
since I was a child I used to like say
I'm going to have a little Farmers
Market we made mud stuff like this is my
stuff like these are our crops and I
didn't need to do that I was four you a
little Matt Damon making potatoes on
Mars
this is the thing this is definitely the
thing and so I know that's what I would
do I would get those kids to like Amish
country and we would make honey and we
would be the weird hippie dippy kids
yeah like I know that what if your
spouse is like what are you doing
can't do CRS I know that they would I'm
sure it would be like that but I can but
the whole point being is that you're
saying we're going to give them a better
life we're the spouse I would have would
be just to stretch this T Leone and be
like we're about to take all the stress
away baby we're about to live a simpler
life she has that card that she plays
multiple times this movie though where
she's like this is the life that we
always dreamed about together that like
this is the house she has this thing
about like even if you gave her a a crap
ton of money and you could move to a
nicer Community within that so like
still keep your friends and stuff she
seems like she's she doesn't want she
wants this house yeah even though it's
not the biggest house even though they
they can barely afford it she wants this
house she wants
she wants shees she's ful embraced what
it is and so even if it's a situation on
paper I don't think that Kate is going
to be up for it oh no well this is the
best part about living in the country
you can have that house for when you
need it but we will live away from
Insanity really wants to be with these
CRS you can't be that stressed out with
your existence and someone say let's
move to the country and like chill out
and not have it be appealing like let's
be world events in the next year going
to make that house seem very less uh
marketable I guarantee you that was the
plan before 911 I bet you after 911 I
could convince her to move with me to
the country that's I mean
yeah out again world events world events
um I do think it's funny that this movie
was buried by Castaway oh yeah Castaway
that's the life you want though no you
want the wison oh I want the cast
away oh I'm right there with I mean but
that's rough R it I'm not trying to
rough it I'm trying to have access to
Amazon let's be real um if I had proof I
could start a fire by myself in in the
I'd be fine living like that's my
biggest worry about that is like can I
start a fire I think we could it looks
extremely difficult I've never done it
if only there was a game show that
stranded people on an island and you
should be on it you should be on it no
uh I don't know if I could do it now but
I know the stuff to make it happen like
I could go investigate how to do it like
the crop Growing Experience I just had
my also if I my glasses I could do it oh
the glasses you do with your glasses
with the magn magnific yeah you could do
with your glasses good luck having those
glasses survive the plane crashed onto
the life rra onto the miles I hope a
whale brought the glasses shot it out
his blow hole and landed on not going to
pretended that but if we had seag glass
we could polish that down you could make
glass that way Cast Away buried
everything though it I mean it was a
huge movie um and yeah this this got
buried by Castaway and what women want
and what women want a big one too that
was a huge holiday hit I just marked the
days where you could have three movies
debut and all everything in that list
made over100 million doll it's crazy
that is not that's not that is not a
thing making money then yeah and it's a
holiday season that's the prime box
office season so everybody can eat I
will say this before we get out of here
I I think I like put it on the Disturbed
One is there a holiday movie that's like
part of your staple is there a holiday
movie that you try to see every year
which one is your holiday like it's in
your top
rotation no matter what I have two
actually every Thanksgiving I like to
watch Planes Trains and Automobiles
already already watched it this
year uh Christmas
Vacation um and I watch Home Alone 2 a
lot I Like Home Alone 2 better than the
one with Trump really W you just all of
that I know it just come through I
between the two home alone I'm going to
pick the first one cuz he's come on it's
the same so you you just because Trump
rolled through it's the same story it is
but you got Tim Curry in the second one
that is a fact doesn't discount that the
first one you have the fake classic film
movie which I thought was a real movie
for the entire time that I watched that
movie until I think we covered it and I
found out sequel to that in Home Alone
too you do cuz he plays it in the hotel
room and freaks out Rob Schneider and
the pranks are funnier to me in the
second one I laughed harder at the
pranks if I've had a couple of Pops in
me then I Like Home Alone 2 better only
because the sticky Bandits are hilarious
and uh but if I'm watching it so I think
the first Home Alone gets me in the
fields a little more and the second one
it actually hurts watching the uh the
the stunts after a while like what like
Kevin is he's literally trying to murder
these these people which he has every
right to do my God I mean like after the
first injury these two should be in the
blue tent in the NFL why they still
coming back like that's my whole thing
like cuz it's a kid no way a kid can
beat us after so many licks you don't
get them back you just lay down no they
know they have to take this kid out now
because this kid is going through
puberty and he we're turning this kid
into Rambo yeah he's going to be a mass
murderer what's your like uh OG my mom
and I have kind of like it's not a hate
watch necessarily because there's parts
of this movie we love but we also love
kind of Mystery Science theing our way
through love actually really I've never
seen that movie there's certain story
lines that are so so so good and or
funny and or touching but then there's
other ones where it's like dude this is
creepy and this is so but there's
there's moments in it there's moments
and you're going to know what what's
good and what's bad watch it watch it
and then hit me up after you do cuz I'm
curious for like everybody has their own
relationship with Love Actually and I
also just love the house swapping of the
holiday the house swap so uh I was say
the holiday is my uh holid very go-to
one uh also Bridget Jones's Diary that
opens on New Year's Day because I'm
actually more of a Thanksgiving New
Year's Day girl Thanksgiving I love uh
New Year's Day for Bridget Jones's Diary
and also for the apartment which is a
New Year's Eve movies so I have like
those are my holiday movies and I would
say the holiday is the Christmas one New
Year's Eve is the apartment New Year's
Day is Bridget Jones okay I mean we know
clearly between the three of us we know
how to Holiday correctly so there's not
a Santa in sight we'll let Tony organize
the Thanksgiving festivities next year
he seems to be championing that we'll
come to his place and watch football
I'll handle uh Christmas and then jacn
gets to ring in the New Year I will I
will make it happen that's a good time
right there I I got black ey Peas on
Deck all right is going to be it for us
in movie talk let's go ahead and get out
of here but before we do Tony I was
going to go ahead and say where can
folks find you and what do you have
going on next if you happen to be in the
Tacoma Seattle area I will be out there
December 7th through the 9th at Nate
Jackson super funny comedy club I will
also be in San Francisco the following
weekend at Cobbs Comedy Club and then I
will round out New Year's Eve weekend in
Orlando for two nights and then New
Year's Eve in Tampa Florida at the EMP
PRS out there so uh those will be my
last cities for the year and I'll be off
the road in 2024 so if you're anywhere
in those areas come see me before I go
on my little Hiatus if you will you're
doing the uh you're doing the three
shows New Year's Eve at at Tampa okay
I'm doing two I three gr it was
disastrous in Virginia Beach last last
at the Funny Bone of Virginia Beach I
did the funny Bor Virginia Beach New
Year's Eve disastrous why the energy was
terrible oh I it was terrible I felt
like they wanted to be somewhere else
three shows is tough because because the
last like the first one's earlier than
you're used to it's like six and then
it's like 8:30 or 9 and then you got to
get that crowd Out full food yeah yeah
they had full meals turkey dressing they
were sluggish the itis was there itis I
did a New Year's Eve at a comedy club
that shelman nam I love this club but
they handed out the the the things you
you people would not you you can't give
give that to a room full of drunks at
right before midnight and expect to any
jokes wh like the whistles on Arrested
Development okay we're going to need to
get them all back Mark where where can
folks find you because I know you got
some tour dates coming up uh after you
check Tony out in Tacoma a couple weeks
after that you can come on down to
Seattle Washington where I'm going to be
right before Christmas the December 22nd
23rd um in Seattle that weekend you get
tickets to Mark ellis. live more touring
in 2024 cuz Tony's taking some time off
so I got all the spot get my spot
give us SP the the road the life of a
road comedian I and check out our show
on the street on on Rotten Tomatoes you
can find it on on social media Instagram
I've had so much fun we have a great
crew they give me a microphone and way
too much freedom to just roam around the
streets of LA hopefully we get to take
that on the road soon so if you're
around Southern California you see me on
the street I'm probably asking you about
movies uh come hang out it's a great
time I love it very similar to that be
sure to check out our new podcast the
awards tour podcast it's hosted by me
for all of those episodes you're like
where's Jaclyn why is she not here she's
probably doing some
awardsyoutube Billy Jean that is right
never seen it with a very special guest
but it was filmed in Corps chrisy Texas
like five movies that were filmed there
well this was Selena right this was the
Selena country in the non Selena Parts
is the best oh wow say this is corvis
Christie of the 70s and early 80s is a
different time so do not put it on
expecting some great Tano music
definitely not okay we're going with the
white trash kids of the lake towns of
corbus Christie but I know a little
something about that yeah it's it's fun
it's a fun ride and we will see you all
next time again I want to say on behalf
of everyone Our Guest Tony Baker Mr Mark
Ellis and our producer Brian Perez thank
you all for listening and we will see
you all next
[Music]
[Applause]
time